hey guys welcome back to some for on our  videos and today like again we have some  beautiful news that i can now wait to  share with you as you can tell by the  title and the thumbnail yes we are  getting new ornaments for every single  hero in for honor this is coming march  ninth which is in two days on thursday  and i will show you all the video very  quickly i just got to briefly explain  part of it at the very end got cut off  so i will leave a link to the subreddit  which will leave the link to the twitch  and then the full video conference of  the devs talking so you can see the very  like five seconds of the video I  apologize if we're being cut off I could  not have stopped that but I will leave  you all with the video and the peace out  guys we'll see in the next one  you